Bell is with us in Kansas City Hidell
how are you Dave this is a thrill thank
you so much for taking my call
certainly and what is your net worth
well Dave I am a 53 years old and I am I
can't even believe I'm saying this but I
am worth about 22 million goodness
gracious
okay break that down for me the big
numbers Dave ninety - ninety-eight
percent probably is in real estate I
when I was about 22 years old I started
buying income-producing real estate and
I've stuck with it I've I've learned it
I've learned everything about it and
I've I love it I'm passionate about it I
every chance I get I tell friends and
family what I've done is oh so 20 20
million dollars worth of real estate
what's the other 2 million my personal
house houses which I guess is real
estate you know vehicles and you know
that kind of stuff so you have
retirement accounts of any kind a very
minimal probably a hundred grand and
some sides so it is truly a pure real
estate portfolio why pretty cool and
what's your degree in Dave I was lucky
to get out of high school and that is an
honest being honest there I'm graduated
in the very bottom on my class I do have
a couple years in junior college I
studied mostly business classes and what
was your GPA in high school I II know
what's been thirty some years ago I have
no idea but no that's what you're saying
so I'm guessing when I get to this debt
question you're gonna tell me you did
borrow money to create wealth that
you're gonna say you borrowed money on
this real estate Dave I can tell you
when I started out buying real estate I
I use a creative financing I'd never
would have dreamt a buying automobiles
or stereos or clothes or vacations with
debt but I have to say I
and I still do today by income-producing
real estate with that but I'm very
careful about it
Donna and I wouldn't well you just work
I mean you killed it here this morning
two million dollar net worths real at
fifty three so what's your highest at
household income year oh there's a last
couple years my tax return is floating
right about a million bucks a year okay
and that's that's rental income yes sir
all right hold on we come back from the
break I got a couple more questions
front for you you're you're off the
charts one here you're an outlier and
I'm gonna learn from you this is pretty
cool very nice this is the Dave Ramsey
show we talk to all kinds of
millionaires millionaires who made their
money in the music business millionaires
who are famous millionaires who aren't
millionaires who borrowed money
millionaires who didn't millionaires who
bought new cars millionaires who didn't
millionaires who graduated from high
school millionaires who have a PhD we
talk to all kinds of millionaires
because all we care about is your
millionaire how'd you do that and if
even if it doesn't necessarily align up
with Dave Ramsey scissors or Chris Hogan
says this it doesn't matter we're
learning from real millionaires how they
really did it and Dell is in Kansas City
he really did it
buying real estate with debt and has a
twenty two million dollar net worth
which means if you have debt that means
your real estate is worth a lot more
than that right now yes sir what's your
real estate worth total I don't know to
be honest with you my debts about
thirteen million so and that would be
those two added together right a million
I mean it would be thirty five million
right
just 35 minus thirteen is 22 if that's
your net worth right yes sir unless I'm
missing something okay so you did
creative financing and you've got a
little bit of debt but your debt is less
than thirty percent of your net worth
you have a small you have a seventy
percent equity position right yes that's
true
has it always been that way or have you
worked up to that I worked up to
when I first started I'd put down as you
know I was broke so I'd put down the
least amount of possible I'd buy a
little single-family house and rent it
for the most possible I'd work on the
darn thing and a couple years later I'd
refinance take that cash and I buy
something bigger so these days i
strictly buy high-rise type apartment
buildings no more single family stuff
i'm hands-on i've worked you know 40 or
50 hours a week i have a great team
behind me a team of attorney and
accountant realtor and architect i treat
them good i pay their bills on time I
give and referrals and in turn they
treat me good how much money of this 22
million did you inherit not a penny not
a penny okay my case I think I'm a true
rags to riches type of guy I come from
what I would call a poor family I guess
my family wasn't in real estate and when
I started that was pre-internet so I
educate admire going to the library I'd
read real estate books I'd read them
over and over and over and it just
clicked with me Dave and I I have what I
had what I call my light bulb moment you
know I had a some goals I wanted to
reach and one day a light bulb went off
and I thought aha real estate is how I'm
going to achieve these goals and I was
always big about making written goals I
always say if your goal is not written
it's a dream and I wanted goals and when
I was in my 20s I said I'm gonna meet
these goals and I did it and I haven't
looked back and I'm still to this day
passionate about real estate I love to
talk about it I love to you know teach
my friends about it Chris Harrison
there's that intentionality it was
running about again it really is letting
all the laser focus and mean and going
in and reading Dave he's pursuing
knowledge what are you already there
well is that what you would tell people
now Adel if you were talking to a
millennial and they said oh you can't be
a millionaire now you have to inherit
all your money what would you tell them
Dave I would tell him to get some
written goals I would tell them to find
what they're passionate about I would
tell them to learn everything they can
about that and
to not stop learning I would tell them
tell them to build that team I would
tell them to live today like nobody so
that tomorrow you know the rest of it
that sounds familiar day later you can
live and give like no one else way to go
down congratulations again Dave not an
accident no in anonymity czar accident